[Music]
good morning everybody it's seven
o'clock hitting president putin where it
hurts or just a slap on the wrist is the
west going far enough with its sanctions
against russia as it sends troops into
eastern ukraine the kremlin seems
unperturbed and many heroes say boris
johnson isn't going far enough all the
while the likelihood of war draws ever
closer in a moment joined by the foreign
secretary liz tross
labour's david lummy the former foreign
secretary jack straw and latvia's deputy
prime minister it's wednesday the 23rd
of february
on the brink satellite imagery shows new
military deployments near ukraine's
border
hitting back western nations punish
russia with new sanctions and threaten
to go further if moscow attacks its
neighbor
who in the lord's name does putin think
gives them the right to declare
new so-called countries
on territory that belonged to his
neighbors
unease and defiance here in the
ukrainian city of harkeev very close to
the russian border amid mounting concern
of a full-scale invasion
prime minister's question time it's
revealed that boris johnson will have
completed his questionnaire about
downing street parties
under a police caution
a wake-up call a warning that eight
million operations could be cancelled or
delayed each year due to a shortage of
anesthetists
flood warning residents in villages in
worcestershire and shropshire urged to
leave their homes as water levels along
the river 7 continue to rise
also ahead wherever you're watching us
around the world this morning feel the
rhythm feel the rhyme they may not have
won gold but jamaica's bobsled team have
won over a new generation of fans we'll
catch up with two members of the team
i actually blind yes i'm blind so i
don't have any sight at all so i can't
see anything
what what
yeah what the heck
and shining a light on disability
speaking to the visually impaired
activists hoping to raise awareness
amongst children
[Music]
good morning everyone the standoff
between moscow and the west over ukraine
is ramping up britain the eu and the us
have slapped sanctions on russian
oligarchs and banks in moscow russian
lawmakers have authorized vladimir putin
to use military force outside his
country
president biden has called it the
beginning of a russian invasion of
ukraine and warned of more sanctions if
the kremlin goes further
who in the lord's name does putin think
gives them the right to declare
new so-called countries
on territory that belong to his
neighbors
this is a flagrant violation of
international law and demands a firm
response from the international
community
the past 24 hours reveals several new
troop and equipment deployments near the
border with ukraine the image shows a
new field hospital has been added to a
military garrison in western russia
they also show more than 100 vehicles at
a small airfield in southern belarus
bordering ukraine they've been released
by private u.s company maxar
technologies which has been tracking the
build-up of russian forces for weeks
well john sparks is in ukraine's second
largest city of kharkiv near the russian
border for us this morning morning team
i'm sure there's significant anxiety
where you are this morning john what are
we making of those satire images
yeah i don't think that they will help
the mood here we've really we've been
here for a couple of days we've noticed
a real shift over the past couple of
days the development of a distinct
feeling of unease about the prospects of
a russian invasion the center of harkev
last night people were singing
popular patriotic songs and they were
shouting sweary chants about vladimir
putin but we went and spoke to people
afterwards asked them about the russian
invasion and you know people are
thinking about it they're thinking about
what they would do personally they've
got plan a's they've got plan b's
whether it is to to fight to resist or
to go
to go and hide you know but people
really are thinking about it it feels
very real and we've seen these
commercial satellite photographs 100
vehicles we've got field hospitals
logistical support staff tents for
troops that thing that sort of thing
really unnerves people here and it comes
at a time when the diplomatic track has
basically ended president biden last
night said look i'm still open to talks
but his secretary of state has cancelled
scheduled meetings with his opposite
number sergey lavrop the french foreign
minister has done exactly the same thing
he was supposed to meet lavrov on
thursday as well but at the moment they
can't seem
they can't really see the point of
talking they just don't have anything to
talk about and that is not good here in
ukraine president zielenski he is under
a whole lot of pressure
he has urged ukrainians to keep a cool
head he has called up reservists here in
ukraine but he hasn't triggered a
full-scale mobilization yet still hoping
that he can avert that the international
community can avert a full-scale
invasion because the consequences are
just too severe for ukraine okay thank
you foreign secretary liz truss with us
this morning morning to you very dire
situation as it has been over the last
few days ratcheting up all the time what
will the sanctions that you impose
yesterday achieve
what what has happened over the last few
days is that president putin has
recognized two so-called independent
republics
in ukraine he has essentially violated
ukrainian sovereignty that is why we
have put together a strong response with
our international allies with the g7 to
target key oligarchs close to putin to
target banks to put in territorial
sanctions
against those
breakaway regions
as well as targeting those in the
russian parliament who voted
for those regions to be recognised we
have not yet seen a full-scale invasion
but we are very clear that if president
putin escalates we the international
community will escalate our sanctions
okay let's unpack that what of what
you've done already will will that
achieve
five what it will achieve is inflicting
pain
on vladimir putin and his regime and the
russian economy we've targeted key banks
that fund the russian military we've
targeted key oligarchs who are close
friends of vladimir putin and what this
shows is that we are prepared to take
tough measures this is the toughest
sanctions regime we've ever put in place
against russia but it will go further
if we see a full-scale invasion of
ukraine and what we're doing kay
is working very closely with our allies
like the americans the europeans so that
vladimir putin cannot play divide and
rule we are completely united in the
sanctions that we've chosen and we will
continue to escalate if vladimir putin
mounts a full-scale invasion of ukraine
so what do you say to those who say it's
a pretty tepid first response that many
of the sanctions against these banks
were already in place um uh when crimea
was annexed by the u.s the u.s
sanctioned it when crimea was annexed
back in in 2014
and the named individuals mess so what
is what's on it saying
well these are very close friends of
vladimir putin they are serious
sanctions we are only able to bring them
in because of the new legislation that
we have passed
in the house of commons but we will go
further
we've been very clear that we're going
to limit russian access to british
markets we're going to stop the russian
government raising sovereign debt
in the united kingdom and we are very
united with our allies in the way that
these sanctions packages are working
it's very important that we stay aligned
and that vladimir putin cannot try and
divide the west he has sought to create
ambiguity to divide the west and divide
nato and he's not doing that we are more
united than ever in making sure that
vladimir putin and the russian regime
experiences pain from these sanctions
and ultimately loses in his attempt to
turn the clock back to the 1990s to deny
the sovereignty of ukraine and to
subjugate eastern europe you say that
the british government is prepared to go
much harder on putin if he goes much
further i mean this is a man
who has sent death squads to kill people
on british soil this is a man that's
authorized shooting down mh17 over
ukrainian airspace and this is a man
that has now invaded sovereign territory
how much further does he need to go
we have put the toughest package of
sanctions on the russian regime we put
them on within 24 hours
of those
so-called republics being recognized by
vladimir putin our officials at the
foreign office working through the night
to get that package ready it is a very
serious package it targets key oligarchs
we're clear that sovereign debt will not
be able to be raised by the russian
government it targets key russian banks
that fund the military and fund the
activities of the russian government but
we are aligned with our international
allies in saying that we will escalate
the sanctions
that there will be
even more tough sanctions on key
oligarchs on key organizations in russia
limiting russia's access to the
financial markets if there is a
full-scale invasion of ukraine which i'm
afraid to say okay we are very much
expecting it's important that we retain
some sanctions in the locker to respond
to a full-scale invasion of ukraine
because we are doing all we can
to deter vladimir putin to inflict as
much pain
as we can on the russian government to
make it clear to the people of russia
that their government is violating
international law is violating
sovereignty so that we need to keep
those sanctions in the locker for that
i'm afraid very likely event
will any of those sanctions be against
tory donors
we are very clear that nothing is off
the table in terms of who we're
targeting in terms of the access of
russia
to british
financial institutions and we are
maintaining uh our alliance with our
international allies to make sure that
we are targeting those key people who
are backing and supporting putin's
regime so you're not ruling out um i
don't rule out anything okay um the tory
party has received something like two
million pounds in russian link cash um
since uh the prime minister took office
should that money be given back
all of donations to the conservative
party are from people on the electoral
register in britain those donations are
properly declared what we're talking
about here kay is people the oligarchs
that we're targeting in today's
sanctions those are people closely
linked to vladimir putin's regime now
there are many people who have moved to
russia from britain who are not
necessarily friends of vladimir putin
and who have become british citizens
that is a completely different matter
from people who are close
to vladimir putin who are backing
his appalling regime so is that i know
the 1.93 million pounds that boris
johnson's government's received since
2019 you're going to keep it
well as i've said all of those donations
are properly declared okay so that's a
yes um can you just clarify for because
i was a bit confused yesterday about
roman abramovic
has he previously been sanctioned or not
because the pm said he had in the house
no he hasn't been previously sanctioned
uh the pm misspoke in the house and the
record will be corrected okay should he
have been should he have been sanctioned
as i've said i'm not going to go into
details of what our future sanctions
plans are but nothing is off the table
because he is of course on the navalny
list isn't he which is a list for the
benefit of our viewers of 35 individuals
compiled by alexander bali presently in
prison and that he uh in his opinion and
those that he represents should be
sanctioned
we have already targeted
some of putin's closest allies with the
sanctions that we announced yesterday
i'm not going to go into details of who
is on our list for future sanctions but
viewers can be assured that we have more
individuals that we will target
in the event of a full-scale invasion of
ukraine and we'll be targeting them in
conjunction with our international
allies like the europeans and like the
united states to make sure
that these people can't travel
though their assets are frozen and that
they will have nowhere to hide and that
is the message we are sending to
vladimir putin and his regime is that we
will inflict even more pain
in the event of a full
incursion into ukraine and we will not
let vladimir putin win what constitutes
a full invasion
well it constitutes um troops crossing
uh crossing the border
well
that is frankly ambiguous at this stage
okay we've heard it so we acknowledge
now that it's ambiguous
we've heard from putin himself that he
is sending in
troops we don't yet have the full
evidence that has taken place what we
are expecting uh and this has been
confirmed by the americans as well as by
the united kingdom
is a full-scale invasion including
potentially of kiev but we continue to
consult with our allies we'd have to
move on vladimir putin constantly tries
to use disinformation he tries to use
false flags he tries to create ambiguity
and what i'm saying is we will not allow
that to happen we will remain united
with our allies we are constantly
watching the intelligence we're working
with each other and we will respond
very swiftly but and severely in the
event of that full income but does it
have to be a move on kiev in order for
you to introduce more sanctions no it
doesn't okay no it does does it have to
be well
it has to be what we would describe as a
full scale invasion but that could be on
other parts of ukraine regrettably
the russian forces are encircling
ukraine so we don't know exactly where
that would happen but we will know it
when we see it and we will react
immediately do you from your
intelligence do you expect him to try to
do that
we do
we think it's highly likely that he will
follow through on his plan for a school
a full-scale invasion of ukraine
and as far as kiev is concerned he's
moving on kiev
we think it's highly likely that that is
in this place
this is one of the reasons kay that we
have advised british citizens to get out
whilst commercial flights are still
available because the situation
is extremely concerning we're doing all
we can to support the ukrainian
government we've supplied defensive
weapons uh we're supplying economic
support we're working very closely i'm
in regular touch
with the ukrainian foreign minister to
provide all the support we can we are
very concerned about the situation on
the ground i was reading a description
about president putin overnight
describing him as cruel autocratic
intolerant and a bully how would you
describe him
well i think the description that you've
read out is entirely fair comment this
is somebody who has acted with impunity
has invaded sovereign states
has now
seeking to
completely undermine the legitimately
elected government of ukraine and he
must be stopped what i can say is
working with our allies we are
determined that his ambitions should end
here um as ofcom is concerned with
russia today it's up to
ofcom whether rush today continues on
with its licence or not and the
suggestions that it's about in
propaganda on behalf of the kremlin what
should ofcom do well i think it is
certainly true that is spouting
propaganda on behalf of the kremlin and
one of the things the kremlin does is
use disinformation to try and sow
discord
in the west and russia today is clearly
part of that it is an independent
decision of ofcom about licensing
broadcasters okay and as far as
champions league final should that be
held in russia or not no it shouldn't be
that
no negotiation that's it i'm very clear
it shouldn't be and the british team
shouldn't go if it is
well
i i don't have any control as foreign
secretary over the british football team
but i'm sure they might seek you but um
the um maybe the scots will get there as
well i don't know
well
unlikely but sorry well watching us
what i'm saying kay is that
the way that russia is behaving we
should not be in any way
seem to condone that behavior we must
condemn it absolutely we are in real
danger at present of a full-scale
invasion on ukraine
and
all we can do to disassociate ourselves
from russia
and this appalling regime we should do
now and here comes a question about the
pm before i let you go he's been
questioned under caution if he's found
to have broken the law should he resign
the pm is completely cooperating with
the police inquiries that are taking
place
i support the pm 100 even if he's broke
i think he's doing a fantastic job and
we have to allow those police inquiries
to continue i can't comment on an
ongoing investigation so james cleverley
said that he works for you actually he
said that if he has broken the law it
doesn't matter he's a good prime
minister he should carry out
i'm not going to comment on hypothetical
questions but i completely agree with
james he's a good prime minister he's
doing a fantastic job we need to let him
get on and do the job it's good to talk
to you thank you indeed thank you bear
with us a second uh the ukraine crisis
is dominating the front pages again this
morning as you would anticipate the eye
says president putin has taken europe to
the brink of war
in the telegraph the u.s president joe
biden says russia has already started to
invade ukraine
and is preparing to advance deeper
excuse me into the country
the mail goes with joe biden describing
vladimir putin as twisted and ready for
bloodshed
the west imposes sanctions as biden
warns of war is the lead for the times
and the ft shows uh russia tanks on the
border with ukraine and says vladimir
putin backs separatist claims for the
whole of the donbass region
and the guardian says the threat of war
is growing
still to come on the programme for you
this morning we'll get the views of the
former foreign secretary jack straw on
the crisis in ukraine
we'll speak to the world health
organization special envoy for kovid 19
that's dr david nabarro as england
prepares to live with kobit from
tomorrow
and we'll hear from labour's shadow
foreign secretary david lammy who says
the sanctions against russia should go
further
[Music]
meantime what are the europeans going to
do about it or laura standing by for us
in brussels this morning laura we've
seen that the germans have acted at
least for now as far as the gas pipeline
is concerned what else do we know
yeah morning kay
yes certainly we saw this uh tough set
of measures perhaps surprisingly tough
coming out of the eu and surprisingly
swiftly as well they decided this so the
eu is going to target 27 individuals and
organizations including banks is going
to target 351 members of russia's lower
house is going to restrict russia's
access to capital markets i.e russia's
ability to raise money to borrow money
but as you say the biggest announcement
came earlier on when the german
chancellor announced the uh the
suspension of nordstream 2 that gas
pipeline running between russia and
germany it's a huge step it'll come at a
big cost to germany but it is a very
significant moment and it sends out a
very very clear and significant message
to president putin now all of the eu
measures will have to be officially
signed off today but that is expected to
happen by this afternoon make no mistake
though this is the eu acting swiftly
acting together and acting very much in
align with other world leaders and i
think like other world leaders the eu
sees this very much as only a first step
of measures and should russia should
putin escalate the situation in ukraine
then i think like the rest of the world
the eu is very much ready and expecting
to escalate its package of sanctions too
okay thank you
nhs will be forced to cancel or delay
around 8 million operations every year
by 2040. if a shortage of anesthetists
is not tackled melano's standing by for
us now hello to issue in the newsroom
this morning hi melania tell us more
morning kay well the royal college of
anaesthetist has warned that it is going
to be a workplace time bomb they warned
that the profession is facing a perfect
storm of a limited number of training
places poor retention of staff as well
as an aging workforce with about 39 of
all anecdotes closing in on their
retirement age now in a report published
today they warn that a shortage current
shortage of at least 1 400 staff across
the uk is leading to around a million
operations a year not being able to take
place and what's worse the shortfall
anita is could reach 11 300 by 2040 and
that means around 8.25 million
operations won't be able to take place
due to lack of stuff now this could all
seriously hamper the efforts to clear
that elective care backlog in the nhs
which stands at 6.1 million currently
just in england so the royal college is
asking the government to fund an
additional 100 training places each year
they also say there needs to be better
communication around career progression
when it comes to that type of specialism
so more young people could be enticed
into the profession and they say if this
is not done the patient care will
seriously suffer there will also be an
impact on the mental health of the
current anaesthetist who are already so
very much stretched okay thank you
major incidents have been declared in
shropshire and worcestershire overnight
as water levels along the river seven
continue to rise two severe flood
warnings remain in place signaling a
danger to life let's find out more
should we katie is in bewdley in
worcestershire for us katie good morning
it looks as though those flood defenses
are holding at least one night
good morning okay well unfortunately
just in the past hour or so the water
has started to creep over the top of the
barriers um here in bewdley you can see
how bad the flooding already is the
water levels are above five meters here
and they are continuing to rise now just
behind me you can see those blue
barriers the temporary flood defenses
that were put in place by the
environment agency as you say
they're just not holding anymore now
people were told to evacuate here last
night when the water levels were already
very high and we understand that most
people have done so although we've seen
someone just in the property behind us
this morning still trying to bail out
the water
with buckets but people
around here that they're pretty angry
you know they are well used to flooding
in these areas but they've told they're
not going to get permanent barriers here
until at least
2020 floor but 2024 but this is the
second serious flood they've had now
within two years and they feel like
they're just pretty much being ignored
um by the government now in the past few
days after storm franklin we've seen
serious flooding not just here along the
river seven but also in other parts of
the country and places in yorkshire
in the northwest as well and there is a
second severe flood warning in place
still today about 20 miles up the river
7
in ironbridge where there is also
a danger to life but unfortunately this
is not the last of the extreme weather
there are yellow wind warnings in place
across the northeast cumbria and
scotland as well as warnings of heavy
snow across scotland and northern
ireland today so unfortunately damage
like this probably isn't the last that
we're going to see okay thanks katie
also making news for you this morning an
armed man who held people hosted for
several hours at an apple store in
amsterdam has been detained by the
police several people managed to escape
during the siege and a hostage was freed
following the suspect's arrest
the three men who murdered ahmed abre in
the u.s state of georgia have been
convicted of federal hate crimes after a
jury decided the attack had been
racially aggravated all three had
initially pleaded not guilty insisting
that they chased and killed ahmed
thinking he was a burglar he had been
out jogging when he was shot dead
britain's biggest housing charity
shelter is warning thousands of renters
could be evicted sky news has learned
that at least four households a day are
being evicted by councils due to rent
arrears
a new study suggests that a cheap blood
test could save the lives of thousands
of heart attack patients the british
heart foundation says the quick test can
help doctors to spot people at high risk
of death following a suspected attack
in a galaxy not so far far away from a
dilapidated doghouse that survived a hit
from a meteorite to a chunk of mars
christie's is hosting a space auction
for wealthy collectors items are
expected to sell for as much as eight
hundred thousand dollars and will
include meteorites containing the oldest
matter humankind can touch according to
the auction house
there we go look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
strong winds will take rain south today
with wintry showers following but
southern britain will be mainly fine
most places will start drive windy but
the far northwest will see rain hill
snow and coastal gales
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now you'll remember of course that
yesterday's date was a palindrome
reading the same forwards as it does
backwards and also mirrored well take a
look at this
as scottish meteorologist scott duncan
recorded a toasty 22 degrees in spain at
22 minutes and 22 seconds past two on
the 22nd of the second 2022.
it's just a shame it wasn't recorded in
timbuktu
i didn't write that i didn't write that
now here's a face you might recognize
from yesterday's show in the daily
telegraph hero raf sniffer dog there he
is hertz
um the first in history to detect
electronic devices yesterday received
the animal equivalent of the victoria
cross for his services to afghanistan
and if you saw him on one of uh with one
of my peers on a different channel
yesterday was he only was being
interviewed and we have what we call a
fluffy mic so we can hear better and
they put the fluffy thing on to protect
it from the wind
kept pulling it off during the interview
i don't know whether he thought it was a
cat or whatever he thought it was but
every time they put it back on he tore
it off again
still got that puppy feeling in him now
is this a picture of mars in the times
no it's new mexico stunning image aptly
named alien throne won the people's
choice award at greenwich's royal
observatory anatomy photographer of the
year competition which is fabulous
and truly crazy paving in the guardian
this is the largest roman mosaic found
in london for 50 years it's found on a
construction site experts described it
as a once in a lifetime find in the
shadow of the shard
coming up we're going to be speaking to
the former foreign secretary jack straw
about the situation in ukraine and also
britain's response what should we do
next all of that to come in just a
moment
hello everyone our top stories for you
this morning it's been revealed that
boris johnson will have completed his
questionnaire about downing street
parties under a police caution
major incidents have been declared in
shropshire and worcestershire as water
levels along the river 7 continue to
rise due to storm franklin
and satellite imagery shows new military
deployments near ukraine's border as
western nations hit russia with new
sanctions
a short while ago the foreign secretary
liz trust told me britain and its allies
are expecting a full-scale invasion of
ukraine and if that happens the uk will
step up its response further
what it will achieve is inflicting pain
on vladimir putin and his regime and the
russian economy we've targeted key banks
that fund the russian military we've
targeted key oligarchs who are close
friends of vladimir putin and what this
shows is that we are prepared to take
tough measures this is the toughest
sanctions regime we've ever put in place
against russia but it will go further
if we see a full-scale invasion of
ukraine
tamara's here um glad to see you got the
memo
so what does that leave us
well look the reaction to boris
johnson's announcement of sanctions
yesterday was much more critical than i
think downing street expected after all
this rhetoric about boris johnson saints
is a full-scale invasion vladimir putin
must not succeed we must see him fail
when he announced three individuals
close to vladimir putin and five of the
smaller russian banks would be
sanctioned the reaction not just from
opposition politicians he called this
limp leadership thin gruel but also from
conservatives there's a growing number
of conservative mps who are very
concerned about the way that russia
about the way vladimir putin has been
behaving and have been increasingly
vocal including people like ian duncan
smith the former conservative leader
saying look we shouldn't do the
sanctions in a first barrage and then a
second one if they extend beyond eastern
ukraine they should feel the full force
now and although liz trust was saying
that these sanctions she believes will
inflict pain she made clear that it's
highly likely that the offensive will
continue and that more sanctions will
follow although actually as the debate
went on late into the night last night
it became obvious that in order to go
further in the way she has been
suggesting for example sanctioning
members of the duma the russian
parliament with asset freezes and so on
you would need more legislation than
we've already got so that might take a
little while to get going so perhaps
that's the reason for the delay but
certainly the reaction from from mps was
we need to do more okay tomorrow's take
nine o'clock looking forward to it thank
you i wonder what a former foreign
secretary in the uh form of jack straw
would do about putin at the moment he
joins us now hello to you mr straw
always good to hear from you thank you
very much indeed for joining us this
morning you know the man how would you
describe putin
well i knew him really 20 years ago
and 15 years ago and what's striking
about him is that
the longer he's been in power
the more authoritarian he's he's become
i mean that's not unusual uh
it's a good reason for having a proper
democracy and changing your your leaders
because even in the position which i
held
after 12 13 years she became extremely
comfortable with the fact that you were
in power and nobody else was um
so
he's very authoritarian very autocratic
and whereas 15 20 years ago
there was a
higher degree of
plurality in russia
uh he's as we know from the killing of
his opponents
um he's strengthened his grip uh on the
the state there he's also uh although he
started as a a kgb operative for a
communist regime he's basically a
russian nationalist
uh and struck with very strong ties to
the
russian orthodox church which is
also also about as well as christianity
and their faith uh about
reinforcing
russia's
particular sense of nationalism so and
and from their point of view they they
feel that uh the west has
taken too much from russia and they want
it back and this is what this uh partly
what this argument is about
and but but when you you get somebody
who's been in power for this long uh
with this much individual power
then when they take things personally
they can take it out on whole countries
like ukraine
so that's what i think about
russia
as for
the west's reaction uh and particularly
boris johnson's reaction i mean if he
thinks this is
these
uh sanctions on three individuals and
five medium-sized banks
is going to fail in his as he said i
think he's mistaken um
it would require i think
much greater international effort and
effort from the united kingdom
government
uh to
put real and serious pressure
on on russia and what i don't understand
i listen to liz trust's
current foreign secretary there is why
they are not bringing forward
uh further uh sanctions and critically
while they're not getting legislation
through they promised legislation the
foreign assets bill
overseas assets bill
to better regulate
people from abroad particularly russians
who were laundering their funds through
london uh it's been delayed and delayed
and the reason for this will be i used
to be in charge of the legislative
program at the last labor government for
a year is that
there will be other people saying well
why are we bothering to do this is you
know likely to
offend
our friends who are making donations uh
to the conservative party so they really
need to come forward with this
legislation very quickly otherwise
picking up what your
correspondence just said
even if they want to take action they
won't be able to
although the foreign secretary didn't
make the point that nothing was off the
table and sanctions against those that
even those that donate to the
conservative party could well happen in
the fullness of time depending on what
uh president putin does next do you
think he ever had any intention
of a diplomatic solution
uh yes i think he probably did provided
it was the solution which he he wanted
if you see what i mean i mean what he's
done so far uh is gained the attention
of the world for sure because if a
country
which is economically relatively weak
but with
very big military force and nuclear
weapons like russia
moves troops 150 000 troops onto
somebody else's border then of course
the world will take notice
and he was
i think hoping
that uh what do you get from this uh is
instability in the ukraine which he's
trying to stir up
uh along
uh with um an agreement by uh europe uh
and the america uh that uh
in those circumstances would ukraine be
allowed
to join nato um pretty extraordinary
demand to make anyway but i think that
so i i i'm from what i how i see it is
that he sort of saw it as a win-win
thing
he'd try the diplomacy
and if that would achieve
uh what he wanted without the use of
military force then fine but otherwise
uh he stopped using military force
okay um
what do you think would make a
difference for putin he's you know he
wanted attention he certainly got the
world's attention now what more does he
actually want
well he wants ukraine i mean there's
if you're a a russian nationalist
uh
the ukraine
was
part of the russian empire it was
the tsarist russian uh empire um
but
wherever putin's
history lesson was really very very uh
defective but as
but i i don't he i think
he's in such an isolated psychologically
isolated uh position
um you saw him um having this so-called
cabinet meeting extraordinary event
where he sits in a little cubicle on one
side of a huge
uh room in the kremlin
uh and his
main advisors
sit about 50 yards away on the other
side and keep drooping to a page
into a microphone
um
so i i think he is very isolated i think
he wants to win and he wants to to work
out a way which he can win that i think
is certainly going to include
acceptance
uh that these two
uh small uh regions but important ones
in the east of the ukraine
um russian for for purposes now
that's going to be if if it's just
the areas which the russian-backed
rebels control
that's one thing but if it's the actual
proper formal boundaries of those two
uh regions then that would cause i think
immense problems um but
you you you'll want to carry on
until he
feels
he's winning now this is why
the british government really do need to
think again
about their weak-willed
uh sanctions
and three banks
three individuals and five banks
is not a way of dealing with this and
they and liz trust says nothing's off
the table well you can always say that's
that's something free what they need to
do is like today
it's been drafted is bring forward
the legislation
to control these overseas entities and
who are laundering them
uh that's that's the the first thing
they should do
okay
um we are out of time but i just wanted
to ask you very quickly um we know that
there was such a kerfuffle um a couple
well maybe two decades ago now when uh
your prime minister was potentially
going to be interviewed under caution by
the police he of course he wasn't uh we
are being told that overnight um the
form the questionnaire that our prime
min our present prime minister has had
to complete was under caution
what happens next
well i mean
formally uh what it's a very unusual
thing to happen
as you remind me um when there was this
so-called cash for honours
thing going on um
in the early early 2000s um
the uh tony blair
was indeed uh interviewed but not under
caution um
and quite correctly cautions are
police are required to caution people
where there is a possibility that they
otherwise they may incriminate
themselves which could be used against
them in a
criminal proceedings so it's serious it
doesn't prove anything else other than
that um where do you go from there well
the police i think paul will be
extremely anxious to ensure they
followed the correct procedures
so they've now interviewed or got into a
completed questionnaire
under caution
um
i think it heightens the possibility
that
mr johnson will receive uh one of these
fixed penalties
um but who knows
it's quite a
big problem this big decision for the
poor policemen who are uh having to
decide
yeah or indeed woman uh it's good to
talk to you as always mr strzok yes
you're absolutely right
thank you thanks a lot
going to be speaking to the world health
organization special envoy for kobe 19
as england prepares to live with kovid
that's next
[Music]
hello again england's remaining coveted
restrictions are being lifted from
tomorrow including the legal requirement
to self-isolate the world health
organization special envoy for kovid19
that's dr david nabarro is with us now
um hello to doctors always great to see
you thank you for joining us um has the
government gone too far in lifting all
of these restrictions
i think that actually i'm quite
impressed by
really what's happening because
there is real a stress on continued
prudence in the face of the virus and
that is what's going to be needed to
live with the covid and prevent it from
coming back and causing trouble it's
going to be a bumpy journey moving from
where we were to where we need to be
and i do urge everybody to remember that
this virus is still around it can surge
sometimes dramatically so do what you
can to prevent transmitting it to others
especially if you feel unwell if you're
not required to isolate i still
encourage you to do so i also encourage
you to protect people who are at risk
older people and people with diseases
but perhaps most importantly because
this virus surges do prepare for the
probability that it will surge again but
overall we have to get on with life we
have to live with it and uh perhaps we
we do have to learn to do it without
restrictions from on high we just got to
do it working amongst ourselves
and what about dropping testing is that
a good idea
well i must say that i believed in the
british approach to testing being really
right at the front end of what needs to
be done i mean i know people who've had
lateral flow tests and been able to
check their covert status before they go
to work every day
people who've used their covet checks to
see whether they're infected before they
go to social events and it really has
been useful at reducing the risk so i i
do hope that people can still access
tests and that those who really need
them and can't afford them will not be
prevented from doing so
if we don't have testing how do you find
new variants that's very difficult
i think that one of the good pieces of
news that i read from the uk is that
there is a plan to continue the
surveillance systems that have been used
to pick up new variants and uh you can't
actually check for a variant on lateral
flow testing but if you've got a
well-organized set set of laboratories
that are doing uh further analysis of
test samples from people around the
country that helps you pick them up so
yes testing i mean if there's not
testing it's very difficult to take the
uk strategy to its limits and i i
suppose i'm hopeful that the people who
can't afford tests will still be able to
get them
but people are not going to go for a pcr
test are they um unless um they think
that they have got covid and the way to
have done that previously was to with
these lateral flow tests so the only way
i'm guessing that we'll pick it up is
through random testing for people who
are traveling
i think it will be
uh random testing for people who are
traveling it'll be more people coming
into hospital in a particular area and
picked up with their covid there it may
be gp sounding the alarm because they
see more people being ill in their
surgeries or it may be just a lot of
absenteeism uh about for people because
you do still feel pretty rotten when you
get covered so absenteeism in schools or
in workplaces
without testing of the kind that britain
has had it's much harder you know the
virus is the problem people the solution
if you want to solve the problem you
need to know where the virus is and so
your question about free testing i know
it's government policy uh but my uh my
approach would be to try to keep the
tests being available particularly for
those who can't afford them particularly
for those who are at risk like security
staff people working in public transport
and of course health workers and what
would you do about um passenger location
forms um doctor i mean they've been a
pain at the best of times for people and
it's been questionable how effective
they have been and yet despite all of
the other sanctions and regulations
being lifted restrictions they're still
in place
yes i i noticed that too
you use passenger locator forms in case
there is a
person with covid picked up on a flight
and you want to find the other
passengers to get hold of them quickly
they're quite a useful part of the
process of tracing where people are when
they're ill
i'd certainly
expect them to continue but i that's why
i also favor maintaining capacity for
contact tracing when you do get a
cluster of cases as a disease outbreak
drops and the numbers of cases reduce
so it becomes more and more important to
be able to do the detective work so that
if you are getting some cases appearing
you can quickly pinpoint where
they're coming from so these kinds of
things like passenger locator forms or
contact tracing systems are particularly
useful in the uh
the downward slope of an outbreak curve
sorry for being technical
perhaps okay but i mean we'd only know
if there was a cluster of cases if
people were poorly enough to either go
to the doctor or to find themselves in
hospital is that not right that's right
so there are parts of what's happening
in not just the uk but in many countries
that are leaving me wondering a bit uh
why they're making these decisions
the basic situation is that as you
emerge from a nasty pandemic or outbreak
the the the emergency is always bumpy
it's always difficult and people are
incredibly frustrated and want to get on
with their lives governments want to get
people moving forward and and the
economic recovery in place but it's
during that time that you really do need
to know what's going on so i suppose if
i had a magic wand
and i wasn't worried about what the
treasury would say i would try to
maintain things like free testing just
through this period until the number of
cases really is down because if you
don't know where the virus is if you
don't know who's ill if you don't know
which parts of the country have got
surges it's super difficult for people
to make informed choices which is what i
understand the uk government and other
european governments are asking their
people to do
okay our fondest regards to the
grandchildren thank you so much oh thank
you as always and best wishes to you and
to viewers fantastic to be in contact
again oh lovely we'll speak to you again
soon thank you very much thank you thank
you quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
strong winds will take rain south today
with wintry showers following but
southern britain will be mainly fine
most places will start drive windy but
the far northwest will see rain hill
snow and coastal gales it's going to be
chilly with apache frost in the karma
south and east
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
still to come on the programme for you
this morning more on the unfolding
crisis in ukraine we'll speak to
labour's shadow foreign secretary uh who
will be joining us in just a moment or
two uh that's off the back of what we've
heard from the uh president of foreign
secretary who says sanctions are in
place economic sanctions have been put
in place they were criticized by
quite a few people yesterday from both
sides of the house liz trusted it's just
our first step wait and see what happens
next but she did go on to say that as
far as the british government is
concerned they are fearing and expecting
a full-scale invasion of ukraine which
includes
kiev
what does david lammie think about that
we'll have more in just a moment here on
skype
[Music]